[MUSIC]
Rose, we're so
excited to have you here today.
Thank you for coming.
>> Thank you.
It's great to be here at Stanford.
It's just amazing.
It's wonderful.
>> Now, I'm not sure if you know this,
but Patagonia is practically
the unofficial uniform of GSP-
>> [LAUGH]
>> Students.
>> There's a cheer around
campus a little bit today.
[LAUGH]
>> In preparation for
this interview, I undertook a rigorous
study to analyze how many GSP wearing-
>> [LAUGH]
>> Students I would find in just one day
on campus, and so without even trying,
I found them In the library.
>> [LAUGH]
>> In the dining hall, in class,
in town square.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And everywhere-
>> In between.
>> That's good [LAUGH].
>> I even found some GSP students clad
head-to-toe in Patagonia in Patagonia.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So, while the GSP students clearly love
Patagonia products, what we love even
more is the company's leadership and
values, and we're really excited
to explore those with you today.
>> Thank you, it's great to be here.
>> So, I'd love to start with your
personal journey before you found your way
to Patagonia.
Early in your career, you reached the
heights of professional success in PE and
in tech.
>> Yeah.
>> You were the CFO of
a public company and later,
the EVP of a private equity firm.
>> Yeah.
>> And in 2006,
you walked away from it all.
>> I did.
>> Can you share with us why?
>> Yeah, so, I think like anyone,
when you start out your career,
you're sort of striving to
figure out who you are.
You're striving to do work
that is meaningful to you,
even though you don't really
know what that is yet.
You're just figuring it out.
And I got to this place where my
Italian immigrant family was like,
wow you've made it.
You're the CFO of a public company.
I was in my 30s and I was also going
through a spiritual sort of journey.
I was studying Buddhism at the time and
I got to a place where my
work life felt completely separated
from my personal life and my values.
And it seemed to be that way with
every one that I was working around,
it seemed that there was this
bifurcation between your work life, and
your personal life and
your personal values.
And I just couldn't bear that anymore and
then I started working in private
equity because I thought I'd have more
freedom, it would be more exciting.
And I was really disappointed by it,
and I know some of you are going to go,
[LAUGH] working price of equity,
so I feel kind of bad saying this.
[LAUGH] But for me personally,
I could see that the buying and
selling of companies made
very few people rich, and
in most cases, in a lot of cases, hurt the
people that were the actual workers, and
the people that had built the company.
So, yeah,
I went on a sort of personal exploration,
I went to India, I took some time off.
I took care of my ailing mom at the time.
And I thought about different things that
I could do with my life and I thought,
well, maybe I should work for an NGO but
then I thought I know nothing about that.
And I thought maybe I should
become a Buddhist nun and
then I thought that's not so great.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
I thought I'd use sort of the skills that
I had, which was making people money,
being a really good operator,
being a good leader, a good manager, but
do something with it that was
more aligned with my values.
>> And I think for many people, this idea
of giving up a path that is safe and
conventionally prestigious
feels very scary.
You actually did it.
What did you learn from that?
Was it as scary as people think?
>> It's funny, the people around me that
were very trapped in their structure were
calling me and saying, you're doing
the wrong thing, you're gone too long,
you're leaving in
the height of your career.
[LAUGH] I mean, it was like, there was
a lot of advice and it was all wrong.
I mean, [LAUGH] that's basically
what I can say about that.
I think that once you know that
you want to make a change,
I think you start to visualize that
you're going to make that change.
>> And it sounds like during that time,
you were reflecting a lot
on what matters to you.
What does the outdoors mean to you and
how did that shape your decision
to focus on the environment?
>> Well, nature, to me,
it's like a spiritual experience.
And it's an experience of awe.
And we don't get a lot of those
experiences I think in our
day to day life, and
we want to protect it.
But I think what was more interesting
to me was that Yvon had this model,
where he was basically saying,
you can have a great business,
you can make quality product, but
you can also do the right thing
by the environment,
by your employees, by your community.
And that to me was like the most holistic
vision of business that I had ever seen.
And I wanted to see if it actually worked,
and how it worked.
And so that's sort of what
brought me to Patagonia.
>> Yeah, absolutely, and so you joined
Patagonia, which, as you mentioned,
is a company with long standing
commitment to environmentalism.
But under your leadership,
the mission has become even bolder.
Patagonia is now in the business
of saving the home planet.
Why did you think it was
important to aim even higher?
>> Yeah, well,
that was really Ivan saying we had so
fully embodied the old mission
statement that we felt the urgency
of the climate crisis and
the extinction that we're facing is so
urgent that we felt like
everybody's mission,
every business's mission should
be to save our home planet.
I mean,
we're facing this extinction crisis and
we can't turn away from it,
and we need the rest of
business to sort of wake up and
turn towards solutions and
innovations and
the things that will help us survive.
>> And Yvon in some ways had this
pioneering, almost anti-corporate vision
of responsible business,
and since you've joined,
you've quadrupled revenue to reach
over a billion dollars annually.
Some people might think that
driving both growth and
environmental stewardship at
the same time is impossible, but
you've seemingly done it-
>> [LAUGH]
>> How?
>> I don't think that they're
disconnected in any way.
I mean,
I think at the foundation of the business,
it's making a great product and
then standing behind that product.
So, I don't think that is
in anyway bifurcated from
caring about our planet and
our environment.
I mean, the businesses was founded
by people who- Yvon himself made so
many first descents and
climbs in his life.
I mean,
they're people that love the outdoors and
saw the changes that were happening
to the outdoors over time.
because if you keep going back to these
places, you can see that they're starting
to degrade or they're being
destroyed by the climate crisis.
So I think Yvon saw that and
it's embedded in the company.
It's been, I think more important in
the last few years because we have so
many climate deniers in our government.
It's been more important for
us to take more of a stand and
I think our customers understand that.
And they've been with the brand
a long time and they appreciate that.
And one of the unique things about
Patagonia is that in many ways,
it's very counter cultural.
You donate millions in Black Friday sales
to environmental organizations, and
you encourage customers to repair and
resell their gear.
And so as a leader at Patagonia,
how do you decide where to place
these bets on being different?
>> It comes out of what's
happening in the moment,
when we donated our Black Friday sales,
it was right after the election.
We were really bummed out about
what was going to happen to
the environmental protections that we had.
We knew that the administration was
trying to get rid of these public lands
designations that were made.
And we didn't feel very
festive that holiday.
[LAUGH] And so we decided that we wanted
to do something that was meaningful.
And since Black Friday is
such a representation of
consumerism in a negative way we wanted
it to be turned into something positive.
And we also wanted to support grassroots
activists that were on the ground and
needed the money to help fight some
of these environmental battles.
>> And some of these decisions,
like the one you just talked about, or
the decision, for example,
to not sell Patagonia vests to companies
that don't share Patagonia's values.
Seem like they require some sort of
prioritization between growth and
values of the company.
And I think a lot of us are looking to
be leaders that work in that space where
we're prioritizing both.
So, how do you actually make
those decisions in practice?
>> Well, I mean, we keep track.
We definitely look at what could
be the impact of certain actions.
But most of the time we're wrong for
the better.
>> Right.
>> And that's typically what happens.
>> Yeah.
>> We just decided last year we
gave away the Trump tax cut.
And this year we had another 10 million
we felt like to give away in addition.
But we thought this year, okay,
we're going to ask our customers to
see if they'll participate with us.
And our customers contributed $10 million
to grassroots activists in 17 days.
And we set this bar thinking $10 million,
we might not get there,
but our customers did it.
And because they're as worried
about the environment as we are.
>> Yeah, I think that's what's so
fascinating about the model.
Is it seems like some of these
moves will hurt profits,
but they end up having
the opposite effect.
>> But
these are issues that are our issues.
They're the issues of our day, and
you can't turn away from them.
If you're business leaders you
can't turn away from them and
say, I'm just going to go make a profit.
And forget about the fact that the planet
is burning, or that species are dying.
Or that there's such gross inequity
between the rich and the poor.
That it's not going to affect me, right?
I think if you grow numb in that way,
then we're probably all doomed.
We need to turn toward it and
actually do something.
>> Yeah, absolutely, and while we're on
this topic of sort of growth and values,
at some point, if Patagonia continues
to grow its retail business,
there could come a tension between that
and sort of the environmental mission.
And so how are you thinking about
the growth of Patagonia's retail side?
Is that going to continue to be a focus or
are new business models going to emerge?
>> Yeah, I mean,
definitely there's a lot going on
in terms of just resources, right?
So we're not going to
have unlimited amounts
of virgin material or virgin resources.
We've known that for a long time and
have been working on all kinds of
recycled and reclaimed products.
Because the reality is,
we're not going to be able to
keep consuming at the rate we're
consuming and still have a planet.
So we need to change the business model.
And that to me is like innovation.
It's really exciting.
The people that we have working on that,
they are stoked about it.
They are blazing new trails and
building new supply chains.
And so, I think that's just part of
the process of understanding that
business is changing and
we need different solutions.
>> Yeah, definitely, and part of
the innovation Patagonia is doing is
moving into this space of food and
agriculture.
So could you talk to us a little
bit about how that plays into
this strategy that you
were just talking about?
>> Yeah, so we've always been looking at
not just funding grassroots activism but
looking at solutions.
Whether it's solutions to supply chain
problems or pollution in the supply chain.
And in the 90s, our founder had sort of
an epiphany about conventional cotton.
It uses ten extra pesticides of
most crops, synthetic fertilizers,
really, really terrible for
the environment.
And he said if I have
to make another shirt
with conventional cotton I'd
rather close my business.
And so he started working on
an organic cotton supply chain.
So we've always been pioneers in organic.
And if you look at 99% of the agriculture
in the US is chemical agriculture.
I'm not going to use the word conventional
anymore because it's not conventional,
it's chemical.
And that's 3 or
400 million pounds of pesticides and
synthetic fertilizers on the soil.
So if you don't think that's
affecting public health,
biodiversity loss,
you're kidding yourself.
So we felt like food was
the best entry way for
people to really understand
that we can use the soil and
we can use the Earth as a regenerator.
And regenerative organic agriculture,
which is just really techniques,
farming techniques,
along with organic,
chemical-free agriculture,
is the sort of solution, I think,
that we need to turn toward
to get out of this chemical
agriculture model that we're in.
So there's some estimates that say
we only have 50 or 60 harvests left.
I know, it bums you out, right?
But in some way,
>> [LAUGH]
>> In some way it should also excite some
ideas about wanting to change it.
And to me, those are the innovators and
those are the businesses that will really
make a difference, the regenerators.
We can have a regenerative economy.
We're going to have to have one.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And
the businesses that are working on it now
will, I think, be the most successful.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
And moving forward, do you see the
agriculture arm being sort of almost as
big, if not bigger than the retail arm?
>> I think it could be, yeah.
And I think we also have set really
strong carbon goals for ourself,
to be carbon-neutral by 2025,
in our total supply chain.
And it's really hard to do it,
but we're working on doing it.
And some of that has to be offset by
sequestering more carbon in the ground,
through different farming techniques.
And so we're looking at that as well.
But yes, to me it's really exciting.
It's more about innovation.
>> Absolutely, and
Patagonia is pioneering all of these
innovative approaches and doing them well.
Your mission is to save the home planet,
and Patagonia can't achieve that alone.
And some would ask how replicable is what
Patagonia is doing, given that you're so
countercultural, long term focused and
privately owned and
what's your strategy for influencing
others in the broader industry?
>> Well, I think the benefit corporation
movement has been a really important
part of showing the business should be
responsible to multiple stakeholders.
When we became the first California
Benefit Corporation in 2011, and
now there's I think 50,000 companies that
are taking the B Impact Assessment and
over 3,000 that actually are certified.
And so I think that's a nice container.
That's a nice model.
I can see the influence now with
the business, Jamie Diamond and
the business roundtable coming out and
saying there should be more stakeholders
than just the financial stakeholders.
It seems to me, obvious there should
be more than one stakeholder.
[LAUGH] And
then you could balances these things.
And I think Patagonia does sort of
exemplify balancing those things.
>> Yeah and one of the things I loved
learning about Patagonia is your
philosophy on sharing best practices.
You share openly and you collaborate
even with competitors in some cases.
Why do you choose to live that way?
>> Well, it just makes because
we're not a huge company.
It just helps innovations to scale,
if we do it and
the North Face does it and
it's it it helps, and
it's adopted more widely by the Gap or
someone else.
It makes a difference and so that's
really the philosophy behind sharing.
And always constantly
being innovative about
what's next and
what problem to solve next.
>> Sustainable consumption sadly does
remain financially prohibitive for
a lot of people and if the goal is to save
the whole planet, how are you thinking
about reaching the wider audience
is necessary to attain that goal?
>> Well, I would hope that there's
enough consumer pressure on brands
that people understand that
if they buy a $2 t-shirt,
it was probably made with slave labor and
poisonous chemicals and
they think twice about
buying that product.
I think that as a brand we've
always had a belief that,
we make a great product.
We'll repair it for you,
if you need it repaired, and it's broken.
So we're in a contract with
our customer that says,
we want you to keep that in use longer.
Because with all the life cycle analysis
stuff we've done over the years,
the most important thing is to
keep your stuff and use longer.
And that's the most important
thing a consumer can do.
And so we'll repair it we'll replace
it if we can't repair it and
we'll figure out a way to recycle
the materials that you have.
But you have to the customer has
their part of the bargain too.
And yeah.
>> And the work that you're doing on Worn
Wear seems to be an interesting piece of
this in a sense that it's
attracting younger customers,
customers who perhaps can't buy
some of the new Patagonia gear but
they're able to buy some of them-
>> Yeah, I mean there's definitely that,
we sell we're selling our
US gear we're sort of,
making sure that it meets the requirements
for being in the secondary market and
that does help attract
a younger customer but
it's attracting younger customers to
us now is really more our activism.
>> Yeah.
>> And the fact that we're standing up for
the things that they care about.
>> And your employees love
working at Patagonia, so
I wanted to spend a few
minutes on corporate culture.
It's not hard to see why they love it from
scaling on site childcare to encouraging
employees to hit the waves
when the stuff is up.
You invest really heavily in your people.
Why do you focus so much on this and
what's the return on investment?
>> Well, let me just say something about
childcare because I feel like that's
probably the biggest
transformational thing for
me personally because I worked in tech
before, and I don't have any children.
So I didn't really relate to
like the kinds of issues that
my employees might have had.
There were cappuccino machines,
and Foosball tables, and
all kinds of cool tech stuff.
But there was no place that a nursing
mom could go and nurse comfortably.
And when it came to Patagonia,
I was totally blown away because there was
on site childcare, there's kids
around our campus all the time,
which is really great because
you see the future every day.
And you have a real connection
to your employees children, and
the next generation, and
that motivates me every day.
[LAUGH] I mean when I see my employees and
their children it makes me think about,
what am I doing for the long-term?
And we subsidize our on-site child care,
but we manage it ourselves.
And we have the lowest
turnover in our female
executives, managers, employees.
We have total gender parity, so
50 50 management women and men,
that comes from having on-site child care,
I believe.
Because women don't feel like
they have to take a break-
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> From their work.
And you lose a lot of women after
they have kids because it just,
it becomes kind of untenable
in lots of ways and
it's not supported in a lot
of working environments.
So that's why I think we have
a really strong great gender balance
company in that way I think it
makes us make better decisions and
the ROI on it I have done a thing
you can look at, I linked on the ROI
there is an ROI on it and
yeah I mean I look at big campus and
like why there is not childcare there.
>> Absolutely, that was going to
be one of my questions is,
why aren't more companies doing this?
And is it really as expensive
as people think when-
>> No, I don't think I really the economic
model is on there, but
it's really not that expensive.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean, to me,
it's the benefits far outweigh the costs
and, we subsidize a portion but
it's not in any way prohibitive or
to our business and
they've been doing it Patagonia has been
doing it since we were a small company.
So it's just built into
the business model.
>> Yeah.
>> An incredible inspiration and
I hope that one that we'll all take
with us as future leaders and implement.
So if we zoom out from Patagonia's
business and culture and
talk a bit more about your
views on corporate leadership,
particularly in the 21st century with
all of the problems that we're facing.
Under your leadership Patagonia
has become much more political.
You mentioned earlier you even
sued the Trump administration for
his plans to roll back public lands.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Why
did you ramp up your political
activism and, in the lead up to 2020,
is this something that all business
leaders should be thinking about?
>> Well, I think we've seen a lot, I mean,
when the administration pulled
out of the Paris Climate Accord.
We're the only major country not in
the Paris Climate Accord, it's a disgrace.
And you saw business leaders step up and
sign a document saying we
are still in on any court or
any team working toward this goals and
I think those the first time
I was like well this is.
Waking up and they're starting to
really participate and take a stand.
And our reaction to what
this administration has done
is I think proportional, given that
the company has always been about
protecting wild places and
protecting the environment.
When Trump signs away 3 million acres
of public land with a stroke of a pen.
We're not going to sit silent about that.
And it was a definitely
a difficult choice to make,
to sue the administration, but it was
the best choice that we had in that time.
And yeah, we'd do it again in a second.
And we've sued him over
the Endangered Species Act.
And they make us briefs on a number of
other issues, and the Clean Water Act.
And we're not going to sit
by while all the protections
to wild lands are dismantled,
we're just not going to sit by and
watch that.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> And
I don't think other companies should
either because a lot of their
they probably be interested to know
that a lot of their employees find a lot
of enjoyment in the outdoors and
spending time with their families there.
And if it's gone because of greedy people,
then we don't get it back.
So yeah,
I mean it feels proportional to me.
I mean people say to me all the time,
you're taking the biggest stand,
but it feels very proportional
to what the company has been
devoted to over the last 46 years,
and what we're keeping devoted to.
>> And you're out there taking a stand
often before anyone else is, and
you mentioned that's not always easy.
What helps you to actually
act on these convictions, for
those of us are hoping to
do that one day as well?
>> Yeah, well I think that Chris Tompkins,
who's on our board,
when I took the job as CEO, said to me,
you don't get points for holding back.
And I thought that was great advice.
And so, I'll always, sort of, had that
in my brain, we shouldn't hold back,
we should do what we think is right
no matter what the climate is and
what the situation is.
And so yeah, I think it's that, and I also
think I work with some amazing people.
And we all have the same values
in protecting wilderness for
future generations and we all care
about wild places being around.
And if they're not we're not
going to have a world to live in.
>> And on the flip side, you have spoken
out against tech leaders for their
sort of refusal to take responsibility for
their impact on society.
Where do you see the sector falling short?
And how can we as aspiring tech
leaders be better in the future?
>> Well, think of how much money like
the few, like richest tech guys are.
I'm not going to name him by
name because you all know them
>> [LAUGH].
>> What are they doing?.
Like going to Mars?.
[LAUGH].
I mean, how weird is that?.
[LAUGH]
>> I mean,
our planet is like,
we are in dire trouble here.
There's unbelievable income and equity.
There's a rise of populism and fascism in
the world, and it's very scary right now.
There's a climate crisis that
is affecting everyone's life and
causing billions and
billions of dollars in damage.
And very wealthy people
could do something really
powerful about it and
I don't see them doing anything.
I really don't.
Self driving cars going to Mars.
I don't get it.
I think it's the reason why a lot
of wealth shouldn't be concentrated
into a few people because
that's what happens.
And yeah, it's not going to make me
very powerful [LAUGH] crowd here but,
you know,
it's just my point of view about it.
>> Yeah.
>> This is why we like bringing diverse
speakers on this place so
get different points of view.
You also have these great thoughts
on the financial system and
the ways in which it's sort of
structurally destroying our planet,
particularly this emphasis
on quarterly earnings.
>> Yeah.
>> And so a lot of us are going to be
going back out into the business and
the finance world.
What one call to action will you have for
us on that piece?
>> Well, I do think that this
quarterly earnings thing is insane.
I was a public company CFO and
I saw people just sweating out,
one set of earning per share.
And it's like, think about your life,
nothing important happens in a quarter.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's such a weird system,
developed by probably just a bunch of
people you wouldn't want to sit and
have dinner with, honestly.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
I feel like it's really
destroying the planet.
Because it's a short term thinking.
I don't want to think about
what happened in a quarter.
I want to look into the eyes
of my employee's child, and
say, what's going to
happen in her lifetime?
And to me it's like the whole
idea of this short term
profit that makes a few shareholders
very rich, it's not a good model.
I mean it doesn't mean
that capitalism is bad.
I love capitalism, I love the competition,
I love the innovation,
I love the working together and
collaboration and the best ideas win.
I love that and that's like the best part
of capitalism and great products and
great services and
disruption and all of that.
So, capitalism needs to evolve.
That's all.
>> Mm-hm.
>> It's not necessarily a bad system.
It just needs to evolve.
And it needs to consider more things
than just a financial shareholder or
quarterly earnings report.
>> Yeah, absolutely, and
Larry Fink of BlackRock just put climate
at the center of his annual letter.
We've seen a lot of talk about
these things in the past.
Do you feel like we're finally reaching
a tipping point where action is coming?
>> I don't know.
I see a lot of talk.
And I don't see a lot of action yet
from that group.
And we don't have time to not have action.
When I say there's 50 or 60 harvests left.
There's a lot of scientists
that believe that.
When we really look at the climate crisis
and how quickly it's come upon us and
pretty much everyone in this room has
been touched in some way by fire or
flood or,
has some relative that's been effected.
And it's only getting worse,
so I don't see
the action yet,
I don't see the investment yet,
I still see using the same measures or
metrics.
But maybe I'm wrong,
maybe I'm not seeing it all,
but
>> I thought we turn now to some of
the broader leadership lessons from
your career and trajectory and
Many of us in this room at
Stanford hope to found companies.
We're known for
attracting aspiring entrepreneurs.
But there's this other equally powerful
path of working alongside founders and
helping to scale their vision and impact,
which is very much what you've
done alongside Ivan Shinad.
What's the most important thing that
you're learned from working with him?
>> Man, there's so many things.
Well he's completely fearless,
whenever he makes a decision,
he doesn't care what anyone says or
thinks or, he's just completely fearless.
He keeps going, and you might get some
noise over here complaints here there but
you know,
just he doesn't let it bother him.
He just he keeps he keeps moving forward.
And he's very self examining.
It's really part of the company culture
to live an examined life and all of us
I feel like do that and
we're all curious people and, yeah.
And I think that and quality.
He's always is really
really focused on quality.
And I think he has a right to
always bring it back to that.
Coz at the end of the day
we're selling a product and
we want that product to be the highest,
possible quality and
we want the relationship
with the customer and
lucky enough to have some of our
Palo Alto store employees here today.
And it's like they do the really hard
work of like expressing the brand
through themselves as people.
And that is always been really important,
you know aspect of the brand.
>> This idea of living a self-examined
life, I wanted to ask you about this.
You have a strong set of inner values that
guide you and anchored in sort of your
Buddhist and meditation practice
that you mentioned earlier.
What role does this play
in your leadership and
what advice would you share with us for
cultivating that inner sense of self?
>> Well, I think it's really good
always to be self-examining and
to be curious about differences.
We've become so polarized as
a country in so many ways, and
yet there isn't a whole lot of curiosity
about why people are different or
why they might have different views.
And and I think my practice
helps me to be more conscious of
the ways in which I fall short myself of,
being self reflecting and, and
meditation is a nice tool.
It really does help you deal when
you're in a high stress job.
It's good to have some tools that work.
For some people it's certain kinds
of exercising or whatever, but
for me it's a real tool to manage my
life and to check in on my decisions and
whether I feel good and right about
the decisions that I'm making for
the company and for myself.
>> Many of us hope to make
pivots throughout our career and
your pivot from private equity to
Patagonia is an incredible example.
How do you shift your mindset to adapt to
the new industry that you're in without
losing the unique insights that
you bring from the previous one?
>> Well,
I think all of your life experience,
it comes to bear in any thing that you do.
And that's probably a common theme,
when you do these talks.
And,.
Yeah, I mean, I think that's probably
the biggest The biggest thing is it,
it's all it all gets incorporated.
If you're a person who lives you
know holistic life and your life is.
Kind of melded together your values and
your work and your life and
I think that's the best way to live.
>> And you have this quote that says
work is where the self meets the world,
which I loved and
many of us are graduating in a few months.
So what is the most important thing we
can do to actually find that alignment
between our work and our value.
>> Well, I think work is the place where
the self meets the world because it's
where you kind of are confronted
with all of these sort of tensions
that you don't have in your family life,
and you have to navigate through them and
difficult people or difficult business
conditions or whatever it may be.
And you learn a lot about yourself
if you're a curious person and
I've learned I learned a lot from
like the bad bosses that I've had.
I learned more probably from the bad
bosses that I have from the good bosses.
There are there things like that, that
in retrospect, when you look back on it,
you realize yeah, I like,
didn't ever want to be like that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Or I want to incorporate this or that,
yeah I mean, I think, yeah,
that's sort of the way I see it.
>> Yeah, absolutely, well,
we wanted to leave time, today, for
questions from the audience.
>> Cool.
>> So, I'm going to turn it over
now to some audience members
who have questions for you.
Great.
>> Hi, I'm Maya Granite, I'm an MBA 2 and
I'm also doing the Masters of
Science in Environmental Studies.
>> Awesome.
>> So if we want to save our home planet,
we need to get a heck of
a lot of people involved.
But the environmental movement is often
associated with a certain demographic,
often wealthier often white and
frequently women.
So, why is Patagonia doing?
And what can we do as future business
leaders to push that movement to
greater representation and kind of
include more people in the narrative?
>> Yeah,
I think that's a really good point.
That's a really good, good question.
So what we started doing
this a few years ago.
With our grassroots giving,
because that seemed like the fastest
way that we could activate it.
And we started just looking for
groups that were outside of
our normal outdoor cohort.
And a lot of these relationships formed
over time just because you've on
met people along the way and
they were protecting certain places.
And so that's how the movement grew.
And so
we took it more into protecting areas that
maybe aren't the grand outdoor places, but
it's a cool group of Latina moms in LA
that are doing air quality testing.
[LAUGH] We wouldn't have even known
about that group before, and so
we just started bringing in these,
we started having kind of conferences with
all these different NGOs and, and just
just like making more connections because
we're all really connected
in the same movement, and
it's just about like making
the connections stronger and deeper.
And I think that's the way that we're
looking at it and we're also you know,
exchanging, sharing learning a lot
from that process as well so.
>> I really thank you for being here.
My name is Ellery and
I'm also a second year,
I'm organizing the climate conference with
Maya so very excited about this topic.
And given Patagonia's 2025 commitment
to being carbon neutral and
the complicated history of carbon offsets,
how does Patagonia think about choosing
office assets that truly
deliver what they promise.
And then secondarily how can we
collectively hold Patagonia and
other companies like Microsoft and
Jet Blue to the commitments they make.
>> Yeah, this is a really good question
because when I first looked at,
I didn't really know much about offsets so
when we first started looking at offsets
as a part of our carbon plan,
someone's told me I could spend $100,000
that could offset all of our, you know,
all of our carbon in the US and
I was like,
that makes absolutely no sense to me.
Like just at a practical
level that makes zero sense.
I don't know where that hundred
thousand dollars is going but
it doesn't seem to be going for
what it's, you know, really going for.
So we're really looking for
like absolute reductions.
By implementing solar grids or
working on energy deals or
working on converting
factories that are using coal,
to using renewable energy and
that's the way we're looking at it.
Offsets, there are some offsets that
are good that are conservation,
mostly conservation related,
the stuff that we're looking at.
And I find that to be a little bit,
to make more sense because conserved
land is a carbon sink and it really,
if it's not conserved,
it's likely to be disrupted and destroyed.
But the market itself is,
I think we have to be very careful about
how people get to that goal and
are they getting to it in a real way?
So, just keep asking those
deep questions because,
that's how you hold people
accountable really.
>> Hi, Rose, thanks for being here.
I'm Caroline Lay,
a first year MBA students.
I have a question about kind of the global
ambition of Patagonia because we all
know Patagonia is in the business
of saving home planet.
And it's such a global crisis and
imperative, especially for
the developing countries,
where we're going to see another billion
middle class entering
the world stage by 2025.
So what is the vision and ambition for
Patagonia, on the global stage?
Do you see more aggressive expansion
of your global footprint, and
how do you balance that with
your integral strategy?
>> Yeah, so it's not really
about growing our footprint,
so much as activating our community
in outside of the US region.
And we've been in Japan for almost 30
years, we've had a business in Europe for
almost 30 years and
in South America, and Australia.
And in all those places what we're
trying to do is, first of all give to
grass roots organizations that
are really doing things on the ground,
and that creates kind of a community for
us, to work with.
And it's one of the biggest changes
that I feel like in my tenure as
CEO I feel really proud of,
is making that mission much more global.
And, we use a tool that we
introduced a few years ago called
Patagonia Action Works, which we're
now long launching around the globe.
And it really is to connect our customers
with our causes, because a lot of
our customers just want to know,
what can I do, can I donate time?
Should I donate money?
What are the right NGOs and so
we're connecting them together and
it's been really powerful.
And we also work on policy issues
with the government, wherever we are,
environmental policy issues and
we stand up as a voice for that.
And a lot of our industry is also
concerned about these issues,
so we work as a convener
to kind of make change, so.
>> Great.
We have time for
more questions from the audience.
So, if anyone else would like to ask Rose
a question, please throw up your hand and
we will get a mic to you, so.
>> Hi, Rose.
I'm Isabel Fisher,
second year MBA student here.
I came to do my MBA because I really
do believe the private sector has a big
role to play in addressing
challenges that face the world.
However, I'm also very aware
that there are certain areas and
certain challenges where the private
sector's role is limited.
And I'd love to hear you
speak a little about,
where you see that distinction lying and
where you see a real role for government,
non-profits or the private sector
>> Yeah, well,
there's a lot of hybrids going on, right?
We notice this whenever we have
to build a supply chain that
hasn't been built before.
It's like you need,
sometimes you need an NGO,
sometimes you need a policy
person in government or
local government and then sometimes
you might need venture fund money.
So there's a lot of
interesting hybrids going on.
And I think that's really the only
way we're going to solve these big,
intractable problems is by
collaborating in that way.
And it means a lot,
even if you're a small business,
it means a lot if you let your voice
be known to your legislatures and
to become active in policy,
essentially, so.
>> Hi Rose, thank you for being here.
I'm First year MBA.
You mentioned a lot of success cases where
Patagonia is able to collaborate with
other NGOs, with the consumers,
even with governments to join the cause.
What are the biggest struggles that
Patagonia is facing when you don't succeed
in doing so?
>> Well, I think the biggest struggles
are just the trying to help people
understand the scope of the problem.
Because a lot of environmental problems,
you can say,
well, we're going to deregulate, round up,
that most people don't think about,
what are the impacts of that?
It's like, well that might help a farmer
if you do regular round [LAUGH] but
what does it do to the stream?
And then what does it
do to the water supply?
And then what does it do
to the biodiversity and
then the animals that
are going to drink that water?
So it's like people have a hard time,
in some ways,
thinking about the causation of
certain policies, especially.
I think that's probably,
the most complicated challenge
is understanding that there
might be a business purpose.
But there is also a better way to do
things, and trying to always look at that.
I mean, we we pollute,
we're a company, we pollute, but
we also understand that's a problem.
[LAUGH] So we charge ourselves
a 1% tax on our own sales and
we give to environmental groups,
that will fight for these causes.
So, I think you constantly have to be,
business has to keep in mind
that they have a stakeholder,
which is the planet and that is a really
hard concept for people to get.
I don't know why,
because we're losing biodiversity
at an enormous rate right now.
We're in the middle of a climate crisis.
I don't know why it is such a hard
concept, but it kind of is.
I mean, it's interesting, maybe that's
something you guys would solve.
[LAUGH]
>> Okay, we're taking one last question
>> Hi, thank you so much.
It is awesome to have an openly,
queer business leader on a stage today.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I'm wondering if you could share
a little bit about some mentors who
have helped you get to where you are,
particularly, as somebody who is out
in a space where there are not a lot of
people who are out?
>> Well, I wasn't out early in my career
because it was not cool to do that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
then when I came to Silicon Valley and
I became CFO, General Magic,
I was like,
I cannot go into this very public role.
Because when you're a CFO, you're on all
the road shows and things like that, and
not be myself.
I just decided I was drawing a line,
I'm not doing it anymore [LAUGH].
And when I told the head of HR,
when they were making the offer to me,
when I told the head of HR.
She just looked at me and said, my God,
I thought you were going to
say you had cancer.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And [LAUGH] [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] And she goes, what do you mean?
It was Silicon Valley.
It was a very welcoming community.
But yeah, I had a boss early in my
career that asked me not to act so
gay in meetings.
I mean, I've had weird stuff
like that happen in my career.
And it's like you just sort of evolve and
you go through it.
Right now it's just such
a part of me I don't even
think about it until you
mentioned it actually.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Great, so,
we usually end our talks on
a light hearted lightning round.
And for this one I thought we
could get the audience involved.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So,
we're going to play a quick game of
Patagonia workforce policy trivia.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So, I'm going to share a series of
policies, all of which are true or false.
And I'd like the audience to just yell out
whether you think they're true or false.
And then Rose if you could
reveal the right answer.
>> Okay.
>> That would be great.
>> I hope I know it.
>> Yeah.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's a critical part of the game.
>> Okay, so number one.
Employees at Patagonia get
every other Friday off.
True or false?
>> [CROSSTALK]
>> Ooh, mixed,
I thought this was the easy one.
>> True.
>> True at our corporate office,
not in all of our stores is true.
We have other ways of doing that.
>> Patagonia sponsors two
months of paid leave for
employees to volunteer with
an environmental organization.
>> True.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Patagonia has a buy-back program under
which it purchases all North Face
clothing from new hires.
>> [LAUGH]
>> False.
>> But maybe a future policy,
we don't know.
Patagonia pays for
its nursing mothers to bring that baby and
a nanny on business trips?
>> True.
[CROSSTALK]
>> Amazing.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Patagonia subsidizes the installation
of solar panels in all employees' homes.
>> [LAUGH]
>> False.
>> False. [LAUGH] >> Okay, two more.
Patagonia rotates its annual retreats
through the US National Parks?
[CROSSTALK]
>> True.
>> Ooh mixed bag.
>> False.
>> False,
but-
>> [LAUGH]
>> It might not be a bad idea.
>> And Patagonia posts bail for
employees that are arrested for
peacefully protesting the environment.
>> True [CROSSTALK]
>> True.
>> True, amazing.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> [LAUGH] Thank you guys.
>> I think-
>> Thank you Karen.
>> At this point we can
all understand why it's so
difficult to get a job at Patagonia.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Rose, thank you so much for coming.
>> Thank you, this is awesome.
>> It's been a real honor and pleasure.
>> Thank you guys, thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]